yeah so we've turned left there
come down it says when you're almost at
the railway Club
it's 5 30 in the morning and the
temperature is barely above freezing
we're out with the rural homeless team
in woods half an hour north of Norwich
walk down a little bit
of over
have a list of sightings
it's a list that's getting longer
could be here so we'll just have a look
around this with this area
as Dawn breaks hidden behind a crumbling
old signal box we find Connolly
hello
Connolly it's Becky from the rough
sleeper team
he's 24 and has been sleeping out here
for the last three weeks
quite a bad fight and um
it caused me to lose where I was living
but not only that I lost my job I used
to be a housekeeper but no I'm after
that night I've sort of lost everything
managed to find this ten for five we
used the last bit of money I had
you obviously get really cold Conley
yeah it is getting really cold now
but you know there's such a risk you
know especially as for people and just
call it get hypothermia and that that's
quite scary
I've definitely hit my lowest point
[Music]
how much of a priority then for you now
is ensuring that tonight he's somewhere
warm that is my priority today that is
my goal to make sure I get back to the
office find him somewhere today and get
him into accommodation tonight now he's
been rough sleeping in a tent
you are picking up a young man called
Connolly
as soon as you can please
[Music]
Conley's situation is not unique the
number of people homeless in rural
England is rising there are a multitude
of reasons less funding a lack of social
housing lower wages and high numbers of
second homes are just a few of them
to be honest in rural communities house
prices rents and so on are completely
out of whack with local wages which
makes it really hard to live in the
countryside unless you're on a very good
salary it's actually the case that the
demand for social housing is increasing
six times faster than the supply
new key on the North Coast of Cornwall
just meters from the beach is the Sandy
Lodge hotel
it's 50 plus rooms are full but there
are no tourists inside are the hidden
homeless
this hotel is completely full of people
who are on the waiting list for housing
here in Cornwall many of them were
working full-time they were paying
private rents and one decision by their
landlord has completely changed their
lives hey Kim how you doing hi Dan nice
to meet you how you doing who's this
this is Charlie how old's Charlie he's
10 months old among them is Kim she her
partner and three kids have been living
in this hotel for four months
so this is your room yeah this is where
we live
so there's the five of you in
yes
my landlords decided to sell the house
so
we were made homeless really
and that's as simple as it gets so
you've gone from a three-bedroom house
to one room one room yeah how do you
feel sort of having privately rented
technically
being homeless now
it hurts it hurts a lot I mean like I
said we were told it was our forever
home we were there two and a half years
and then we were given two months to
leave
and it's like
you know there's so many second homes
there's so many airbnbs there's so many
places that could be used
to house local people especially
but there are a lot of people I think
that come down from up country with the
idea that cornwall's the best place ever
and
it's really not like it's beautiful but
is not under the surface
living in one room for months on end
with no end in sight is taking its toll
all we want is a home
that's it my kids my four-year-old cried
on Christmas Day because all she wanted
from Santa was at home
and you know it broke my heart because I
can't give her that at the minute I
don't have the means
I don't have the money to be able to do
that and I'd give
I'd give anything to be able to get home
for my children
funding to help people like Kim is a big
problem researchers from the
universities of Kent and Southampton
have recently found that government
money for local authorities to tackle
homelessness is 65 percent less per
person in rural areas compared to Urban
and while the overall number of homeless
in the countryside is lower than in
cities that number is rising sharply
exclusive analysis for Sky News by cpre
the countryside charity has found that
the number of people homeless in rural
England has risen by more than 21
percent since 2018. there were more than
17 000 people classed as homeless in
rural areas in 2018 to 19 but last year
that number jumped to nearly twenty one
thousand rural parts of the East and the
south west of England have the highest
numbers
the situation is so bad here the
Cornwall council is spending 40 000
pounds every single day putting people
in emergency accommodation and he'll put
it bluntly at the moment we just haven't
got enough housing available for local
people to buy or rent you know there's a
shortage of housing full stop
one temporary solution is to build
dedicated pods so behind you right now a
15 solar house units each one
accommodates one person and they provide
a stepping stone for people who have
through no Faults of their own have
found themselves in in need of a house
the council wants up to 500 of them
placed in pockets of land where people
need the most it's Cornwall council's
number one priority is to address the
housing crisis what we've seen is over
the last number of decades a a a slowly
building crisis that was exacerbated by
the pandemic which was acted as a
catalyst to really
highlight the amount of housing
inequality across Cornwall
building more social homes is the
council's long-term plan but that will
take years right now Millions is going
on temporary solutions it's a huge
amount of money but it has provided
provided a necessary service
however temporary accommodation isn't
good enough
I think we need more social housing and
more
um sort of sufficient longer term
solutions to the problems that we face
the government says building more
affordable homes is key to solving rural
homelessness but that simply isn't
happening anywhere near the level that
it needs to be so at the minute you've
got a lot of sticking plaster Solutions
but we have heard of one place back in
Norfolk that's doing more to help the
homeless than just putting a roof over
their heads
in a place called ditchingham there's a
massive old Convent in 2011 a group of
nuns gifted it to the homeless it's run
by the charity Emmaus companions as
they're known are given bed and bored
but they also work a 40-hour week paid
in cafes and shops that they set up
firstly people are supporting themselves
so they're not getting a handout so we
are supporting people to gain self-worth
and maintain that and build skills and
build their self-esteem to a point that
they feel able to
move on potentially
Chloe's 22 and was living in her car
before coming here she says having a
home and a fresh purpose has saved her
life
they've got me through so much mentally
through my addictions absolutely
everything family stuff every aspect
they've got me through more than what
anywhere else has to be honest so they
have they've saved my life in in one way
so
because I could if I didn't have here
I'd be back in my car on the streets and
I'd probably relapse and be drinking and
using again
in some of our most rural areas becoming
homeless is an ever-growing risk
the government says it's giving councils
366 million pounds to help house those
in need and has built more than 243
000 affordable homes since 2010 but
campaigners say it's not enough
first and foremost we need to see a
massive social house building program
which we haven't seen in this country
for years and we want a significant
proportion of that for Rural communities
where the problem is particularly acute
that's the only way to solve this in the
longer term it's something that we've
really under invested in in this country
and that's what we want to see change as
soon as possible
in Norwich there's been a change of luck
for Connolly okay
come food just eight hours after we
found him in a tent he's been given
somewhere to sleep for at least eight
weeks
they definitely moved quickly
I was actually a surprised on how quick
they managed to get me into a room
um food parcel
um you've got fridge in the microwave
there's some toiletries I'm just so
relieved I'm really grateful you know
for what they've done you know helped me
uh come here because I'm definitely
gonna sleep well and it'll take a few
days to adjust
but it's definitely better than being
outside
for Connolly it is a chance to rebuild
but not everyone facing homelessness
gets this opportunity in what is a
growing crisis in rural England